[Musique]
à sainte maure de touraine ont vibré ce
matin aux sons et aux couleurs du
drapeau américain
une bannière étoilée pour se souvenir
d'un homme william elle pawlowski
lieutenant de l' us air force touché par
un tir allemand il ya 77 ans jour pour
jour tellement de soldats ont donné leur
vie soldats étrangers ont donné leur vie
pour que la france soit libéré et nous à
sainte-maure bien sûr ce soldat
participer parce que nous étions occupés
par les allemands cet aviateur
malheureusement qui faisait partie d'une
escadrille de 6,1 perdu la vie et on
voulait marquer ce moment tragique de la
vie de ce soldat et pour notre nation et
notre pays parti de la base anglaise and
over à bord de son bombardier p38 le
jeune pilote de 25 ans avait pour
mission de détruire le viaduc de benno
point stratégique reliant la ligne de
chemin de fer paris bordeaux jean paul
ii sachets 94 ont aujourd'hui se
souvient parfaitement de ce drame qui
s'est noué dans le ciel de son village
j'avais 18 ans à l'époque et ayant
entendu les avions nous sommes en tête
qu'un ami sur le toit de la maison et
j'ai assisté au drame à la chute de
l'avion on a et b est très attristé et 2
ce décès de cette personne de ce pilote
était mort en somme pour nous pour nous
libérer
c'est quand même
poignant de voir un jeune jeune
personnage comme ça a donné sa vie pour
défendre un pays qui n'est pas le tien
une plaque commémorative en l'honneur du
lieutenant pawlowski a été dévoilée à
l'issue de la cérémonie une façon de
sceller à jamais le sort du héros de
guerre avec celui de sainte maure de
touraine